ah c'est découvert par hasard un soir on
se disait qu'on pouvait sûrement faire
une super fête sur un toit
pour moi c'est la plus belle vue de
Shanghai
mais amoureux de cet endroit on revenait
assez souvent et là on voit vraiment que
c'est
c'est tout dans la tout dans la hauteur
[Musique]
et tous les petits quartiers qui sont en
bas c'est des petites maisons c'est des
maisons qui sont amenées à disparaître
d'ici 5 ans
les promoteurs immobiliers veulent
racheter la terre aux gens qui sont là
et ce qui leur donne en général c'est
500 euros par mètre carré et vous
reconstruire une tour équivalent à
celle-ci dans laquelle ils vont ils vont
construire quelque chose qui vaudra 3500
euros du mètre carré et ça la nuit vous
allez promoteur donc quand on voit des
ce qu'on m'a appelé des émissaires pour
mettre le feu aux maisons pour casser
les maisons pour faire partir les gens
et les gens les gens appellent la police
disent bah il y a quelqu'un qui est venu
détruire ma maison qui est venu me faire
peur pour que je parte et la police
répond qui viendront pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est génial ça on est sur nineau
Rhône c'est des plus grandes avenues de
Shanghai c'est une avenue piétonne et
comme vous pouvez le voir les Chinois
aiment assez d'un
donc là juste là c'est la ville et en
fait on s'aperçoit que la vieille ville
c'est un vieux village de pêcheurs parce
qu'il fait chaud dans le fleuve qui
était là
[Musique]
ça rappelle un peu doux c'est parti
c'est vraiment l'origine de Shanghai
c'était juste ça
[Musique]
les côtés et laisser la longueur sur le
dessus
donc là on a une agence immobilière et
en fait vous voyez à peu près vous
pouvez deviner ce que c'est donc là vous
avez 16 mètres carrés et c'est 80000 par
mois
et après pareil 10 mètres carrés 50 50
euros l'une des mètres carrés
c'est une chambre il y a tout dans la
chambre et il faut faire avec
[Musique]
ce que j'appelle le challenge in food
c'est la nourriture où il y a un petit
peu un challenge à manger ça donc là on
n'allait pas de poulet pas de canard là
on a les le coup le coup du poulet tête
de canard on a le
[Musique]
sera très peu à manger chez lui sortira
au restaurant parce que manger au
restaurant ça coûte moins cher que
d'aller faire les courses pour se faire
à manger et donc au final pour une
question de rapidité de prix du coup ils
vont rester là